to security experts who watched the
january 6th riot at the capitol
memories of the 2012 attacks on u.s
embassies in tunisia
and sudan came to mind my drop jaw
dropped because of the fact that it
happened
to see people
in the united states doing this as
opposed to what happens overseas
keith eustis is president of fabrication
designs inc
a manufacturing firm that makes
reinforced doors and windows for u.s
government buildings
his products were not installed at the
capitol
where a mob successfully broke through
using their fists
and a flagpole that allowed them to
enter
through the through the openings of the
glass and
i really felt it needed to be stronger
perimeter
the nonpartisan task force charged with
reviewing security after the capital
breach
agrees its report recommends reinforcing
doors and windows
the deployment of mobile fencing and
retractable barriers
the hiring of more than 800 capital
police officers
and a more efficient decision-making
process for security leadership in a
crisis
more than 5 000 national guard troops
remain
protecting the nation's capital a
jarring site for americans who are
unaccustomed to seeing their military at
work
outside of natural disasters or foreign
wars
but these troops will eventually go home
the plan is to replace them with a rapid
response team of local guardsmen
who could deploy to the capitol at the
first sign of trouble
and after the suspension of six capitol
police officers for their alleged
role in supporting rioters on january 6
background checks are recommended for
all identification card holders who work
at the capitol
if people are going to be here
protecting us we'd like them to go
through the same background checks and
security assessments
two months after the riot the so-called
people's house
still stands behind barbed wire and
armed guards
security experts say the u.s capital can
return to its normal look
we do it either with additional concrete
and steel
or we do it with laminated and
polycarbonate type
glass or you know steel
doors etc but also all of that can be
hidden the cost of the security
recommendations run
hundreds of millions of dollars and some
members of congress have already
bulked at the price but included in the
report
is a warning the threat from domestic
extremists
is growing and the need to arm a robust
defense
is urgent heidi joe castro al jazeera
washington